so with with my dad right there's
moments where i realized oh damn this is
when dad wasn't around this is some of
the things that would have been dope for
dad to be around there's no animosity
there but there's an awareness of where
the void is so now i take that and i
make sure i apply it to mine i don't
want to duplicate that so let me make
sure i give that energy i don't feel
like that's hurt i feel like that's
me being aware of something that i do
feel like oh [__]
yeah this would have been dope i can't
change it still love you dad but that
would have been dope yeah i'm trying to
define more of those moments because
like you said you start to realize where
you could be
[__] up towards others based on his
other baggage that you have so i i ask
you that because of the self-discovery
like how do you get to the point where
you're like oh wait end this
oh wait this could be another thing yeah
you know what i mean oh wait hold on
wait here's something else that happened
that's right it's that is that exactly
what you're doing
it's it's like really like things don't
happen to you they happen for you
that's life everything is life it
happens for you everything is for your
greatest good mm-hmm no matter what it
looks you i mean you know they say you
want to make god laugh tell them your
plans right you can't you can't control
the future i mean you can control it up
to some point you can't control what
others do you can't control anything
someone can run a red light and that's
the end of everything you know you just
you can't you only can control what you
can control
so things don't happen
to you they happen for you so when you
when you look at those situations i had
a similar situation with my pop not
being around as well and then
you know what cracked the code for me
was like really
like what was he going through
hmm
i took it like that perspective yeah it
was like it's happening to me he's doing
this to me
and when i looked at it from his
position like my dad wasn't around and
you know all these things happened and
then when i took a further look his own
his his my uncle his his younger brother
got killed
so he spent all his nights like looking
for the and the cops
didn't do anything so the killers like
roaming the neighborhood so he's going
out in the middle of the night and he's
looking for the you know the guy who
killed his little brother
right but he has a family so my mom is
looking at him like
what you want
she don't have the language or the tools
to tell them man we love you we don't
want nothing to happen to you we need
you right so how it comes out to her is
where the hell are you going you got
kids here and how it sounds to him is
you want me to choose between you and my
baby brother you don't give a [__] i
all right now there's the fracture
right so
among other things you know that this
relationship and there's their
relationship not ours
not ours as children that's their
relationship so there's a fracture in
that relationship and you know things
happen and you're a result of those
things so you feel
you feel that boy dad's not around
it would have been dope if he'd been
able to take me to a baseball game and
all these things and then life on top of
that like he can't get a job because you
know the guy at the office is cursing
him out making him feel less than a man
but he got to take it because he needed
the 1250 a hour 1250 hour he needed 6.50
an hour at that time
you know what i'm saying so life beating
them down so he comes home he's defeated
he don't you know he told to pick you up
on saturday he's exhausted
you know like so you we don't we don't
factor those things in you don't look at
things through those lenses yeah so you
know seeing things from other people's
perspective you had to just answer to
your
long answer but seeing things from other
people's perspective and what other
people are going through you know
helps me a lot you know it helps me a
lot and was that was that was that
somebody else that helped you get to
that like did you is that therapy is
that is that group is that art of
therapy part of being who i am you know
but definitely a lot of a lot of therapy
a lot of you know uh
you know looking at yourself and and and
wonder girl cause we we we've been
taught everything i've been taught
everything but emotional intelligence
wow
you know that's not what you're taught
as a young man growing up in the
projects you're taught to survive
you